boneless wings are basically just
nuggets I'm emotional about this one
this grinds my gear do they actually
debone this and also if you're eating
bones just tender you're a I'm a
yeah you're a bro if you
don't eat the cartilage on the side of
your wings and you do bone the swing
stay home and Order chicken nuggets
order from McDonald's okay what if you
got the wings right but then there's not
meals
on the side why don't you just order
mussels hey can I get a bunch of mussels
and Bone please with some muffalo sauce
he's upset this guy who doesn't
understand how they make this it's
called processed food I like boneless
too I like just the flats you're still
the bone Zone we're still in the bone
Zone
if you order a steak will you get it
bone on or bone off
when you're on a date I'm like ripping
World Peace